Good afternoon, everyone, and welcome to this mini symposium on non-coding
RNA, regulation of cancer hallmarks, therapeutic resistance,
and biomarker discovery. It is really a pleasure
to chair this session and introduce such
an outstanding group of speakers.
I am Emanuela Ferracin. I am a scientist at the University of
Bologna, and I will chair this session.
Want to introduce?
Okay. Over the past decade, non-coding
RNAs have evolved from being considered transcriptional
byproducts to key regulators
of cellular identity and disease.
We now appreciate that diverse classes of non-coding
RNAs play fundamental roles across essentially
all hallmarks of cancer.
And today, we know that these molecules are not only
mechanistic regulators, but they are becoming
increasingly actionable, serving as drivers of tumor
progression, mediators of therapeutic resistance, and
promising biomarkers and therapeutic targets.
Their relevance is demonstrated also by the over 200
posters that are presented this year at the
ACR meeting.
And this mini symposium brings together a set of
presentations that span the entire spectrum
of non-coding RNA functions and activities.
We will start with Dr. Hung, who will discuss the
regulation of ribosomal RNA synthesis in acute myeloid
leukemia and highlight how increased ribosomal RNA
production represents a therapeutic vulnerability.
Then we will move forward toward other topics
involving the study of how non-coding RNA mediate
radiation resistance in cervical adenocarcinoma by
Mingji Zhu.
And then we will discover with Ahmad Ziyadeh,
innovative targeting strategies for the tumor
microenvironment in renal cell carcinoma.
We will hear from Katie Swankut,
the emerging and fascinating area of mitochondrial transfer
RNAs and how they modify breast cancer
development and metastasis.
Yori Kohando will take us into the clinical and diagnostic field,
presenting a high compelling study on urinary extracellular
vesicle microRNA profiling.
And Amartya Pal will close the session with an
exciting example of therapeutic innovation, presenting
multimodal microRNA-based
strategy designed to overcome resistance to PARP inhibitors in
ovarian cancer.
Together, all the presentations highlight a central concept,
that non-coding RNA are very relevant
regulatory hubs in cancer, regulating multiple
oncogenic pathways, including metabolism, ribosome
biogenesis, cell survival, and thus offering a
very unique opportunity for therapeutic intervention.
So as you listen, I encourage you to think two
possible question to present to the speaker at the end of each
session, because we will have time for
discussion, and especially to
focus on how we can today try to transfer all
our knowledge on non-coding RNA toward the bedside and
toward discoveries that have a real clinical
impact. So this is my pleasure to introduce
our first speaker, Dr. Hung.
Good afternoon, everyone, and thank you to the organizers for this opportunity.
My name is Putzer Hung, and I'm a postdoctoral fellow in the lab of Dr.
Vikram Palkar at the University of Pennsylvania.
Today, I'll be sharing some of our developing work on the characterization and
targeting of ribosomal RNA synthesis in acute myeloid leukemia,
AML.
I have no financial disclosures.
AML is one of the deadliest blood cancers in adults, with
five-year overall survivals of only 20% to 30%.
Relapse and therapy resistance are common, while second-line treatment options
remain limited, underscoring a major unmet clinical need.
A defining morphologic feature of AML cells is the presence
of enlarged nucleoli, shown here by the red
arrows, which are sites of ribosomal RNA or rRNA
synthesis.
rRNA are specialized non-coding RNAs that form the catalytic
cores of ribosomes. As you can see in this cryo-EM structure,
rRNAs depicted as colored ribbons make up about half
of the ribosomal complex. Their production is therefore an important
control point in ribosome biogenesis, and more broadly, protein
translation. However, the regulation of
rRNA synthesis across different cell types and in
cancer remains poorly defined.
Within the nucleolus, ribosomal DNA is organized into
hundreds of these nearly identical tandem repeats.
These rDNA loci are transcribed by RNA polymerase I
or Pol I, to initially generate a nascent
47S rRNA. This is a highly active process where
you can have up to 100 Pol I molecules transcribing a single
rDNA locus at a single
time.The
precursor of the nascent RNA is rapidly cleaved into these
mature
rRNAs that are then assembled into the 60S and
40S ribosomal subunits.
Our big picture questions were then, one, how is rRNA
synthesis differentially regulated during normal and malignant
hematopoiesis? And two, is dysregulated rRNA
synthesis a targetable dependency in AML?
To address the first question, we developed a FISH flow assay
to measure
nascent and mature rRNAs at the single cell level
in primary human hematopoietic cells.
We obtained fresh bone marrow aspirates from healthy donors and AML
patients at the hospital of the University of Pennsylvania, isolated
the mononuclear cells, and performed antibody staining to define specific
hematopoietic cell populations.
We then fixed the cells and hybridized them with fluorescent probes
targeting the rRNAs of interest, then measured the probe signal in
each cell by flow cytometry. As shown in these wide field
images, the 47S rRNA probe in purple colocalizes
nicely with Pol1 in green, confirming its
specificity.
And here are our results. On the x-axis are the
different hematopoietic cell types we profiled, and on the
y-axis are the relative rRNA levels.
Nascent 47S rRNA on the left is a
readout of synthesis rate, while mature 18S
on the right is a measurement of ribosome content.
The black dots represent healthy donor cells, while the red
dots represent AML blasts.
Along with normal hematopoiesis, rRNA synthesis and ribosome abundance
decrease with differentiation. For example, along the
erythroid lineage from the MEPs to the
ortho-erythroblasts, both 47S and 18S levels
decline as cells mature, consistent with the shutdown of global
transcription that occurs at later stages of red cell development.
Oh.
And while there is variability among the patient samples depending on the
genotype, treatment status, and aspirate quality, the
overall trend shows that both nascent and mature rRNAs are increased in AML
cells compared to normal hematopoietic cells.
We are still in the process of collecting more samples to obtain more robust
significance, as well as a more representative picture of RNA synthesis across
different molecular subtypes of AML, so stay tuned on that.
To investigate how RNA synthesis is regulated, we then used a
tuneable mouse AML cell line model expressing a HOXA9 estrogen
receptor, or HOXA9ER, fusion protein that is
activated by estradiol. HOXA9 is a master transcription
factor that is overexpressed in over 70% of AMLs and
blocks myeloid differentiation.
In this system, HOXA9 activation maintains a leukemic state,
while inactivation induces differentiation to monocytes.
We found that rRNA synthesis rapidly decreases when
HOXA9 is inactivated and is restored upon
reactivation. And importantly, this occurs before major cell
cycle changes, suggesting that rRNA synthesis is an early
downstream pathway of oncogenic signaling.
We also observed that mRNA and protein expression of
Pol1 subunits are significantly reduced following HOXA9
inactivation. And consistent with this, our single-cell
RNA seq analysis showed that Pol1 expression is elevated in
stem and progenitor cell populations from AML patients
compared to healthy donors. These findings suggest that oncogenes
drive RNA synthesis in part by upregulating the
rRNA transcriptional machinery.
This led us to then ask whether targeting Pol1 could
suppress leukemogenesis. To test this, we generated a degron
system in HOXA9ER AML cells by fusing an
FKBP domain to POLR1A,
which is the catalytic subunit of Pol1, allowing for targeted
degradation of the tagged protein when treated with a small molecule called
dTAG, as shown here in this western blot.
Pol1 degradation led to dose-dependent reductions in rRNA synthesis,
as well as progressive G1 cell cycle arrest.
And interestingly,
persistent Pol1 degradation not only reduced proliferation and
reduced cell viability, but also induced differentiation of
these AML cells, as evidenced by downregulation of a
stem marker c-Kit and upregulation of mature myeloid
markers such as Ly6C, as shown here.
We hypothesized that rRNA hypersynthesis maintains
a stem-like state in AML cells that supports self-renewal
and resistance to pro-apoptotic signals, and that blocking
this pathway would sensitize these cells to
apoptosis-inducing therapies such as venetoclax, a
BCL2 inhibitor that is currently FDA approved for frontline AML therapy.
Notably, HOXA9ER AML cells are TP53 null,
and making them highly resistant to BCL inhibition.
However, Pol1 degradation synergized with venetoclax in suppressing
their growth, as shown by these dose-response curves
here,
where the x-axis represents different concentrations of venetoclax.
The y-axis represents the different degrees of
inhibition, and the different colored curves represent different concentrations of
dTAG. As you can see, increasing concentrations of
dTAG shifted the curves to the left, indicating
that Pol1 degradation potentiates the inhibitory effects
of venetoclax. And here is a 2D synergy plot summarizing that
data. Basically, the redder the color-The stronger
the observed effect is over the expected additive
effect. And a Zipp score of greater than 10
indicates drug synergy. And finally, here
are the percentages of the Nexan 5 positive
dead cells after 40 hours of drug treatment.
So dual Pol1 and BCL2 inhibition has
a synergistically lethal effect on AML cells in vitro.
And what is not shown here is that this synergy
was unique to
dTAG and venetoclax, and not
seen in dTAG and other cytotoxic agents, suggesting
that this is a unique interaction between the rRNA
synthesis and BCL2 pathways.
We also extended these findings to other human AML cell
lines using a small molecule Pol1 inhibitor and observed similar
synergy across the board, regardless of TP53 mutation
status.
So in summary, we've shown that, one, rRNA synthesis and
ribosome content are increased in primary human AML cells.
Two, rRNA synthesis and Pol1 expression are driven by
the oncogenic HOXA9 transcriptional program in myeloid cells.
And three,
Pol1 and BCL2 inhibition synergize to kill AML cells in vitro,
independent of TP53. Together, these findings
identify RNA synthesis as a therapeutically actionable
dependency in AML and suggest a strategy by which we can
overcome venetoclax resistance in refractory or
relapsed disease. We are now
validating this effect in our AML mouse models and
investigating the mechanism of action underlying the
synergy.
With that, I'd like to thank my mentors, colleagues, and funding sources
listed here. Thank you everyone for your attention, and I'm happy to take any
questions at this time.
Hi, very nice work. I wonder a bit between the immature
and the mature
RNA. Do you see differences there?
So let's say you see the good correlation in
the normal cells, but in the AML, maybe the
maturation
differs a bit, or do you see anything
of that, or is this all the same? Once you have high of
one, you have also high of the other one, and there's no
difference in between different cells.
Yeah. So you're asking, do we see a discrepancy in the
nascent versus the mature-
Yeah
... rRNAs, right?
Mm-hmm.
That's a good question. So we generally see that it correlates pretty well.
If you have high nascent RNA levels, you have high
mature RNA levels as well.
But the degree which you see an increase in nascent
RNA is not exactly the same as the increase that you see in the
mature RNA levels.
But we do see a similar trend.
Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
Hi. Klaus Grimosa from the company WMT.
I have more technical question-
Yes
... actually following up to that.
How do you actually determine the rRNA synthesis rate?
And more specifically, how do you normalize it? Just on per cell count?
Yeah.
Because rRNA is typically a normalizer,
but it's 9% of what you determine.
Yeah, that's a good question. So
you're right. We use nascent 47S RNA
levels as a readout for
synthesis rate. It's not
an exact measurement, but because the nascent RNA is so
short-lived, on the order of less than 10 minutes, we feel like it's
a decent approximation of RNA synthesis
rate. Right now we're sort of confirming this by using
things like EU, which actually label
nascent RNA synthesis to sort of confirm the
accuracy. And the second question you had was on normalization, and
you're correct. So this has been an ongoing
technical thing we've been working on.
So what we've done, and because there can be experiment to experiment
variability, and as you know, the machine might be a little different from day to
day, depending on the weather.
What we've done is we've actually spiked into each of our samples,
a cell line, for example.
The cell line we use is MV411, and we just normalize against that
in all of our samples.
Okay. Thank you.
Mm-hmm. Thank you.
Is there any other question?
Okay. It's a very nice talk. I want to add Dr.
Hung has received a foundation award from AACR.
And to continue the discussion, I have one more question.
Yes.
What are your thoughts on targeting RNA polymerase
one
for this disease?
Yeah, great question. So it definitely is a
viable strategy. Right now we're trying to see if there's a therapeutic window.
Pol1 is an essential part of the cellular machinery,
and we're hoping that
AML cells are more addicted to this pathway and therefore more
sensitive to perturbations in polymerase one levels.
Of course, that might not be the case, so the other thing we've been looking at
is, are there any other
mechanisms that could explain
why there's elevated RNA transcription in
AML cells? And polymerase one and the transcription
machinery aren't the only factors that regulate this process.
If you rememberThis is really interesting about our DNA, is that there
are hundreds of copies of our DNA
repeats in the mammalian cell. We have 300 to 500 copies.
And these copies are not all active.
Some of them are actually silent. So are there mechanisms
that convert these silent rDNA loci into
active ones? And so we're looking at the mechanisms that regulate
that as well. And if we can find that there's a difference in normal cells versus
leukemic cells, that's another pathway that we could potentially target.
Wonderful. Thank you.
Thank you. Thanks everyone.
Hey, good afternoon, everyone. Thanks for coming here for this talk.
I'm Shailendra Dwivedi. I'm Assistant Professor at University of
Oklahoma Health Science Center, and I am a co-chair
for this session.
And I will be happy to introduce our next speaker, Dr.
Zhao. Dr. Zhao is from University of Texas MD
Anderson Center. And today she is going to discuss about
the role of long non-coding RNA
CYP4A22 antisense 1
and YBX1 axis in
radiation-resistant survival adenocarcinoma. Dr. Zhao.
Good afternoon. I'm very honored to have the opportunity to stay
here to present our work. Today, I will discuss a
long non-coding RNA, CYP4A22-AS1,
drives radiation resistance in cervical adenocarcinoma
through YBX1 and PDK1 axis.
Let's discuss a fundamental issue in radiation
oncology, why some tumors are intrinsically
radiant to radiotherapy.
I have no disclosure.
The incidence of oral cervical cancer is decreasing,
but the incidence of cervical adenocarcinoma is still
increasing, and these tumors respond very poorly
for radiation therapy. In clinical, we
treat cervical adenocarcinoma in a similar way with
squamous tumor, but they are biologically different.
So we still don't know the molecular basis of
radiation resistance in cervical adenocarcinoma.
As we know, the majority of human genomes encode
non-coding RNA, such as lncRNA. In our lab, we
are focusing on the biological function of lncRNAs these years.
And we know that some lncRNA could bind with DNA and
regulate the transcription of genes.
And some lncRNA could bind with RNase and regulate
the translation and RNA degradation.
And some lncRNAs could act microRNA sponges, and
some RNA could
interact with proteins and
regulate the nuclear translocation, and some other
lncRNAs could encode small peptides.
So we are thinking about that, if lncRNA is a good idea to
find a mechanism why cervical adenocarcinoma
resistant to radiation.
And there are two important things we have known.
The first one is long non-coding RNA regulates stress
adaptation, and the second one is metabolic
reprogramming influences radiation response.
But we still don't understand the mechanistic link between
RNA regulation, transcription, and metabolism in
radioresistance.
So we compare the expression of lncRNAs between cervical
adenocarcinoma and the cervical normal
tissues using TCGA database. And we got
386 lncRNAs
upregulated in cervical adenocarcinoma.
And we also compared the expression of lncRNAs
using our cancer data, and we got
364 lncRNAs
upregulated in cervical adenocarcinoma.
So we got 12 genes, and we also
performed the survival curve of these lncRNAs,
and we found that the first and second, they are associated
with poor survival of cervical cancer.
But the biological function of the second one, we didn't get positive
data, so we chose the first one,
CYP4A22-AS1, as our candidate.
Now, we performed the survival curve of
CYP4A22-AS1 using TCGA database, and
we found that the patients with high expression of
CYP4A22-AS1 had a shorter overall
survival. And we also performed the survival data
using our cancer center data, and we found that patients with
high expression of CYP4A22-AS1 had a shorter
disease-free survival. That means this lncRNA could
predict unfavorable clinical outcome of cervical
adenocarcinoma.
And before we try to find the mechanism of this
lncRNA, we need to make sure some features of it.
According to the prediction using website, we found that
this lncRNA does not encode a protein.
And we also performed the nuclear cytoplasmic fraction
assay, and we found that this lncRNA enriches in
nucleus.
That means the function of this lncRNA may be protein interaction
and transcription regulation rather than
translationSo we want to know if this lncRNA
could regulate a cell proliferation, and after we knocking down
this lncRNA cervical cancer cells, we perform the CCK-8 assay,
and the results show that CYP4A22AS1 depletion
could inhibit cell proliferation.
And this result was validated by EDU
assay. And this means maybe this lncRNA functionally
important for tumor cell growth.
The very important thing is that if this lncRNA
has a relationship with radio resistance.
So after we knocking down this lncRNA in cancer cells,
we expose the cells to six gray radiation, and we
perform the tune assay to test apoptosis.
And we found that CYP4A22AS1
depletion increased the
apoptosis. And we also performed the Western blot to
test DNA damage marking. And we found
that CYP4A22AS1 depletion increased
radiation-induced DNA damage marking.
So that means this lncRNA protects the tumor cells from
radiation-induced damage.
After we knocking down this lncRNA in cervical cancer, so we want
to know the downstream genes regulated by it.
We performed the mass spectrometry, and we found that the
most genes upregulated by this lncRNA were enriched
in glycolysis pathway. So we want to know if this
lncRNA regulate cell glycolysis of cervical adenocarcinoma.
We performed SEAHorse assay, and we found that
CYP4A22AS1 depletion decreases
cell glycolysis. That means metabolic adaptation
contributes to radiation resistance.
There are totally 11 genes are upregulated
or were enriched in glycolysis pathway.
And we perform the qPCR assay to validate this gene
expression. And we found there are four genes, they have
consistent data according to proteomic data and the
qPCR validation. And we also perform the survival curve
of these four genes. We found that only PK1 is
associated with poor survival of cervical cancer.
And after reading the published papers, we know that
PK1 is a key glycolytic enzyme, linking the
transcriptional regulation to metabolism.
So we chose PK1 as our candidate target gene
and think PK1 as a key factor of our lncRNA.
And so we want to know if PK1 is very important,
and PK1 depletion could rescue
the radiation resistant of cervical cancer.
So after we knocking down PK1 in
CYP4A22AS1 overexpressing cervical cancer,
we exposed the cells to six gray radiation, and
we performed the tune assay to test apoptosis.
The results show that PK1 depletion increased the
radiation-induced apoptosis.
And we also performed the Western blot to test the DNA damage
markers. The results show that the PK1 depletion
increased the damage signaling.
So that mean PK1 depletion is very important for
our lncRNA.
And it is a critical downstream effector of
CYP4A22AS1.
And we also want to know if PK1 depletion could
rescue the cell glycolysis enhanced by this
lncRNA. After we knocking down PK1 in
CYP4A22AS1 overexpression cervical cancer cells, we
performed the SEAHorse assay, and the results show that PK1
depletion decreased cell glycolysis.
And now we want to know the relationship between the PK1
expression and the survival of the patients.
For the patients with early stage, maybe we will give them a
radical hysterectomy. For these patients, we test the expression
of our expression of PK1, and the results show that patients with
high expression of PK1, they had a shorter disease-free
survival. And for the patients with advanced stage,
maybe we will give them a radiation therapy.
For this patient, because they have advanced stage, maybe radiation
is proper treatment for them. We found that patients with
high expression of PK1 protein expression, they had
shorter progression survival. That means PK1
correlates with poor clinical outcome of cervical
adenocarcinoma.
Now we want to know how CYP4A22AS1
upregulate the expression of PK1.
Firstly, we performed RNA pull-down assay using
CYP4A22AS1 probe and the antisense
probe. And we also performed the following mass
spectrum, and we found a list of proteins could bind
with lncRNA. And after reading the published papers, we
found that YBX1 is a transcription factor, and it
has multiple functions, including RNA alternative splicing
and RNA stability. And considering
CYP4A22AS1 predominantly
enriches in the nucleus, so we think that
maybe we could choose YPX1 as our
candidate.
And we also performed the RIP assay to validate the
binding between this lncRNAs and the YPX1 proteins.
And furthermore, we try to find the specific binding site
between this lncRNA and the YBX1 proteins.
And the next step, we will continue to design and
construct the mutation of binding
sites.We also performed the
CHIP-qPCR assay to validate, and we found that
YB1-AS1 is the transcription of PGK1.
And we also performed the FRET fluorescence, and we found that
CYP4A22-AS1 promotes YB1-AS1
nuclear accumulation.
And this data was validated by nuclear-cytoplasma fraction.
So we want to know if YB1-AS1 is required for the proliferative
phenotype driven by CYP4A22-AS1.
After we knocking down YB1-AS1 in
CYP4A22-AS1 overexpression cervical cancers,
we found that these genes will increase
the proliferation phenotype. And this data was validated by
EDU assay.
And we also found too, YB1-AS1, it is very
important for the CYP4A22-AS1
reduced the radioresistance. So after we knocking
down YB1-AS1 in CYP4A22-AS1 overexpression
cervical cancers, we performed and exposed
cell tumors to the radiation with six gray,
and we found that YB1-AS1 is required for the
radioresistant phenotype driven by
CYP4A22-AS1.
And we also performed the Western blot to validate this data.
And we also want to validate if
CYP4A22-AS1 accelerate tumor growth
in mouse model in vivo, and we constraint
mouse models using CYP4A22-AS1 overexpression and
knocking down, and the result show that this lncRNA
accelerates tumor growth in mouse model.
In summary, in tumor cells, CYP4A22-AS1
combined with YB1-AS1 protein, and activates the
transcription of these genes, and enhance the
glycolysis of tumor cells, finally promotes the
radiation resistant of cervical adenocarcinoma.
This study provides a new lncRNA driver of radioresistance
and a mechanistic link between RNA regulation and the metabolic
adaptation, a potentially targetable pathway in a clinical
resistant tumor subtype. And this work highlights a
previously unrecognized assets that may be
therapeutically exploitable in cervical adenocarcinoma.
Finally, I would like to thank to Dr.
George Calin, and thank to the college in Dr. Calin's lab.
They gave me a lot of help and support in the bioinformatic
analysis and the performing of the experiment.
I also want to thank the college in Dr. Wang's lab.
They gave me a lot of support in the animal model and the radiation
treatment and the evaluation of the
response. I also want to thank to Dr. Clary.
He gave me a lot of support and helpful comments about the
revision of manuscript. Last of all, thank you for your listening.
Would like to have questions.
We have time for a couple of questions. Is there any question?
Yes.
May I have a question? And I wonder about this
lncRNA. Have you checked its expression across cancer types,
like from the pan-cancer view, will such
lncRNA have elevated or abnormal expression in various
cancer types?
Thank you so much for your question.
Because I think that for the tumors, heterogeneity is very
important thing, and
most of the lncRNAs expression in specific
tumors. Because I'm a surgeon,
my major is about gynecological oncology, so most
of my time is pay attention to the cervical cancer.
So, I didn't check the expression in the
pan-cancer. So maybe in the future, I will check the
expression of them. Thank you.
Thank you.
Hi. Very nice talk. I just had a question.
In your initial slides, you mentioned that there was 12 lncRNAs that
were overlapping between the TCGA and the CHL dataset.
Are you guys also looking into the rest of those lncRNAs besides this one?
You mean that, before my
project, I tried to find, lncRNAs or
upregulated using TCGA database.
Mm-hmm.
But as you know, the sample size of cervical
adenocarcinoma in TCGA database is very little.
Mm.
So I validated expression using my cancer
hospital data. Yes. Thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you. I just have a brief question.
Do you have any evidence that if hypoxia can interfere with this
axis or not in the tumor, if there is any
association with also the context of a-
Thank you for your question
... hypoxia tumor.
Yes. You may let,
maybe in the future, I will test in tumor samples, but
I still don't have the evidence at this moment.
I just checked the binding between this lncRNA and
proteins in cell lines. But I-
Okay
... next step, I will do this.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Okay. Thank you very much. We...
Okay. Now I introduce,
sorry, Ahmad Ziada.
He is from Amherst College. Sorry, I didn't meet you before.
Please.
He will talk about the
impact of miR-196 in renal cell carcinoma.
Hello everyone. My name is Ahmed and I'm a student at Amherst
College.
And here I'm presenting the project I worked on at Zoughbi Lab
at Harvard Medical School.
So here we're interested in remodeling the RCC-associated
fibroblasts via microRNA-196b,
antagomirs, and COP TF II inhibitors using ultra-small
lactoferrin lipid
nanoassemblies.
I don't have any disclosures.
So starting with the problem, despite all the advancements
in immunotherapy, RCC continues to be one of the
deadliest types of cancer all over the world in terms of numbers of
cases as well as
deaths. And a big part of that is due to the dense
tumor microenvironment that surrounds the
cancer tissue. And this tumor microenvironment is
largely attributed to cancer-associated
fibroblasts.
As we know, fibroblasts are these cells that are stromal and part
of our connective tissues. They're responsible for secreting the
extracellular matrix and wound healing.
But in some types of diseases, as in the case in
RCC, they transition from a quiescent stage into a
chronically active stage that constantly produces a very
dense tumor microenvironment that acts as a physical
barrier around the tumor tissue, as well as
suppresses the immune system. And that's the challenge we're
trying to tackle at two levels. The first level is at the
level of post-transcriptional gene repression
using microRNAs. As we know, microRNAs play a very important
role in cancer.
A lot of work has been done on microRNA in the cancer tissue,
but here we're interested on focusing on it as a therapeutic
target in the CAFs, or cancer-associated fibroblasts.
Second, we're interested in remodeling the CAFs at the transcriptional
level. A lot of work has been showing that
the
transcription factor COP TF II,
which is a transcription factor that's normally active during
pregnancy and cell differentiation.
But in the adult case, normally this transcription factor
goes into a quiescence. It's not active anymore
in gene expression. However, in fibrotic diseases,
this transcription factor becomes active again and
promotes gene expression again. So we're trying to tackle that as well
using a small molecule inhibitor, which I'll call
CIA1. So hopefully through this dual
approach, we're hoping to remodel these CAFs into a
quiescent stage again without inducing any toxicity
into them, so that the immune system is more equipped at
targeting the cancer tissue as well as immunotherapy can
be complemented as well. So,
here first starting with the engineering challenge, because we're
using two different types of molecules, we would need a certain
platform to deliver these into the cells and into our
in vivo models. So CIA1 is a small molecule inhibitor.
It's a hydrophobic molecule. So for that, we're
using lipid nanoassemblies where we're intercalating
the CIA1 into the lipids.
For the microRNA inhibitor,
as we know, nucleic acids have a negative charge due to the
phosphate group in the backbone. So we're using
electrostatic interactions, using cationic lipids that
have a positive charge to load the microRNA
inhibitors into our nanoassembly.
The nanoassembly then would be stabilized by lactoferrin
protein, which is a biocompatible protein, very frequent
in milk and other bodily fluids.
Lactoferrin as well,
its receptors, LRP, are known to be up-activated in
the cases of fibrotic diseases like RCC on the fibroblasts
as well as on the cancer cells, which will help us in
the selective intake of our nanoassembly into
our targets.
So first we need to identify the microRNA to target.
We performed microRNA sequencing to identify a
potential microRNA to inhibit. And our
selection was on the
microRNA-196b, which was the most consistently
upregulated in
kidney cancer patient cells compared
to normal. So we got the antagomir or the
inhibitor for that.
After that, we
synthesized our nanoassembly and we did
the characterization. The first thing is, since we're targeting the
kidney, our goal would be for our nanoassembly to get
filtered, to get through the glomerular filtration.
And the
threshold for that is between six to eight nanometers.
So we got ultra-small nanoassembly that's around
6.3 nanometers in diameter, and we're hoping through that
ultra-small size, it will get through the filtration, and through, as I
mentioned, the upregulation of the lactoferrin receptors, it will get
uptaken again into the renal tubules instead of being
excreted through urine. Another challenge that we need
to pay attention to is that since we're using cationic
lipidsTo load our microRNA
inhibitor, we don't need a positive charge on our
nano assembly since this will result in cytotoxic side
effects. So we tuned the molar ratio, the NP ratio in
our nano assembly, and we reached
a nearly neutral zeta potential, which is the potential
difference at the interface of the nano assembly with the
solution. We confirmed the size and the uniformity
and the morphology of the nano assembly using Cryo-EM.
And after using patient-derived CAFs, we
noticed that the treatment with-- So here we're using the
treatment separately first to show that both can have an effect.
Both the antagomer and the SiA1 managed to
down-regulate the activation markers of CAFs as
well as the ECM markers, which are the markers responsible for
this really dense tumor microenvironment surrounding
the tissue. Here we show alpha-SMA has been
down-regulated, which is one of the main activation markers.
PDGF, R-beta,
periostin, podoplanin,
as well as the ECM collagen I, and here we're showing
LOX, EL2,
tenascin, and CTGF.
We're also showing a quiescence marker, P27.
As we mentioned, our goal here is to induce quiescence into the
CAFs.
And quiescence means just
metabolically active but not
actively differentiating. And that's our goal, since, as I
mentioned, in the case of fibrotic diseases, including RCC, they
are in a chronically active stage.
And here we show upregulation of P27.
We also showed that the secretome profile of the
CAFs has been down-regulated as well by focusing on the
cytokines and the chemokines, especially IL-6, which is a
famous pro-inflammatory cytokine, IL-8,
MCP-1, which are involved in angiogenesis.
We also showed CXCL12, which is responsible for trapping the
immune cells in the tumor microenvironment and preventing them
from getting
to the cancer tissue. We also showed MMP9, which is an
enzyme famous for being produced in these
cases of diseases to break down the
tumor microenvironment or the ECM and build it again from
scratch in a way that the cancer is hijacking the
ability of the CAFs to secrete the ECM
environment.
Now, after doing the work on the CAFs, we took the conditioned
media of the treated CAFs and cultured
human renal cancer cells in that media to show any effect of
our treatment on the renal cancer cells without
directly treating them. First, we show that the stemness
through CD44, the stem-like properties of renal cancer
cells, has been down-regulated. We also show the EMT markers have been
down-regulated as well through N-cadherin and vimentin, but we don't
notice any down-regulation at the level of proliferation
through the nuclear marker Ki-67.
We also are showing that this co-culture with
the conditioned media is resulting in the
down-regulation of the migration properties of cancer cells, which
is really important to prevent metastasis.
After inducing a wound in the cancer cell
culture, we track the cancer cells over time, and we show that
the cancer cells that are cultured in the conditioned media of
treated CAFs migrate much slower.
Here we show the quantification, which is really important when we talk
about metastasis.
Now, going to our orthotopic mouse model.
We induced a RENCA model
in mice, and it's a syngenic model,
so not immunocompromised. And here, a really important
thing to focus on is that we want selective biodistribution of
our nano assembly into the tumor kidney because we're
inducing tumor in one of the kidneys.
We don't want our nano assembly to go somewhere else and result in
unwanted side effects. So here, through the in vivo imaging,
we're showing selective distribution of the nano assembly into the tumor
kidney.
And an important issue in the development of
nanomedicines is the unwanted accumulation
in liver and spleen, since when you're injecting it into blood,
the blood cells would go into spleen and result in side effects.
We're showing that there's minimal distribution.
Here we're showing that there's a kind of significant distribution
in the lungs, which is something we're interested in because the lung is
one of the common metastasis locations for RCC.
So we're hypothesizing, and we're doing more work on showing
that the nano assembly is not just going to the kidney, but it's also
going to the metastasis site, since the LRP
receptors would be upregulated there as well.
And here we perform the treatment.
I'm showing here visually the tumor kidney, the control.
And here we're showing the immunotherapy
effect. There's some decrease, but not much.
Here we're showing the separate treatments through the antagomer and the
SiA1, and then the dual nano assembly.
And then here we combine everything together, and we show that the
tumor volume and weight decreases to something really similar
to the normal kidney. And here we're showing the quantification.
Here's the combined treatment in black.And here's
the immunotherapy in red.
And as I mentioned, there's not as much decrease when
using the immunotherapy separately from our treatment.
We're also here are showing that the treatment is not inducing any
systemic side effect on the mice in terms of their weight.
We're showing that the weight stays fairly consistent,
except at the beginning, there's some decrease, but then it
goes back to its normal
level.
Here we did
staining for the sections from the in vivo model.
And here we show again that the ECM and activation
markers are downregulated. But here, as I mentioned, since
we're using a syngenic
model, we can also track the immune system response.
So here in the
middle of the slide, we're showing the increased
infiltration of immune cells into the tumor tissue,
first through the CD8 marker, which is the cytotoxic
T cells. There's
increased expression of that
CD11c, which is for dendritic cells that are really important in the
recruitment of T cells, as well as the marker
CD335 for NK cells. At the same time, we want to show
that the immune system will also have immunosuppressive cells,
such as Tregs and myeloid-derived cells.
And here we're showing to the right that FoxP3, which is the
marker for Tregs, is downregulated, as well as
the granzyme B1, which is for the myeloid-derived cells.
CD44, as we showed in vitro, is here also downregulated,
and that's the stemness marker, which is something we're interested on
focusing on
later.
I'd like to thank my lab members as well as the funding source
for the project, and I'm happy to take any questions. Thank you.
Is there any question from the audience?
You have a question.
A fantastic work. So let me start by the time they are formulating their
questions. So, in the patient data, I see you have
used the three sample. You started with the three-patient sample, N equals
3. Have you looked into the expression of this mirror into the broader
patient sample or cohort?
Yeah. So we started with three patient samples. That's true.
We took them from a collaborating hospital.
But we're interested
more in showing the expression of that microRNA
using more broad data. Yes. We have not looked into that.
Okay. Good.
I have also a technical question. Do you have any idea of
introducing a targeting strategy to your nano
assemblies to, let's say, enrich the accumulation
in cancer fibropolis?
Yeah. That's a good question. So one potential approach would be
to use, for example, an antibody for
PDGFRß to increase the targeting.
But here we're thinking that our main priority is to get through the
filtration
barrier, so we would need an ultra small size, and using an
antibody
could interfere, might increase the size.
Even a little bit can result in a significant effect.
So that's why we're not.
Okay. So connected to this topic, how long does
it last, the effect of your treatment?
Do you have to re-administer frequently?
Do you have any evidence of the-
So, currently for the
initial animal study that we did, we did it twice a week.
But of course, more work need to be done on the long-term effect if there's
any relapse
in that sense. So we're working on that right now.
Okay. Thank you so much. Oh, there is a question.
Hi, very nice talk. I was just wondering, is there a possibility
to
see
if there is any adverse effects
that result from this type of therapy?
Yeah. That's a good question.
So one effect
I would say is that, as we mentioned in the previous question, we're not
using a really active targeting technique.
We're just relying on the upregulation of the LRP
receptors in CAFs and cancer cells.
So one thing that needs to be considered is how
much is our nano assembly going into targets we don't want to
go to. And, as I mentioned, that's something we're working on right now.
Another thing to consider is the effect of the direct
treatment of our nano assemblies into cancer cells,
and that's something also we're doing right now.
Thank you.
Yep.
Thank you for the fantastic talk.
Thank you.
Oh, there is one question. Go ahead, please.
Hi, great talk.
Thank you.
I was wondering if you've expanded your studies into other cancer
lineages that have similar tumor microenvironments that might be CAF heavy as
well.
Yeah. So in the lab, we're mainly interested in fibrotic
diseases. We have a project that's mostly done on
PDAC, and currently we're working on
the CIA1 that we're using here, in the case of
Crohn's disease and pulmonary fibrosis, since
we're seeing it consistently upregulated in different types of
fibrotic diseases. So we're exploring CIA as a
potential
therapy for these types of diseases.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Our next speaker is Dr. Katie Schwankert.
She is from University of Kansas Cancer Center.
Dr. Katie's research is focused on genetic and molecular
determinants of metastatic progression.
Today, she is going to talk about
mitochondrial tRNA and breast cancer metastasis.
Dr. Katie.
Thank you very much. I have nothing to disclose and only
10 minutes to tell you that mitochondrial
single nucleotide polymorphisms, or SNPs,
correlate with metastatic burden,
that this did not appear to be affected by metabolism.
So we asked, could metastasis be mediated by
mitochondrial genome-derived non-coding RNA?
We identified tRNA fragments that differ based on
the mitochondrial SNPs, and I'll show you some early
characterization.
Our colleague, Kent Hunter, at the NCI, asked a very important
question: What is the role of host
cell genetics in metastasis?
He did this by crossing Bill Muller's original PyMT breast
cancer mouse, that's in the FVB background,
with female mice of different inbred
strains.
The F1 progeny developed mammary tumors that
metastasized to different severities based
on the maternal genetic component.
A confounding variable in this experiment was the mitochondrial
genome, maternally inherited.
You may think to yourself, the mitochondrial genome might be too small to
contribute to something as complex as metastasis.
It's only about 16 kb and encodes two
ribosomal RNAs,
13 protein-encoding genes that are all involved in oxidative
phosphorylation, and 22 transfer RNAs
which shuttle amino acids during transcription.
Excuse me, translation.
In order to study the mitochondrial genome in a
non-mutagenic context, we use mitochondrial
nuclear exchange or MINX mice.
By pronuclear transfer, we're able to mismatch
the strain of origin of the nuclear genome with the
mitochondrial genome. We use a two-letter abbreviation code
as a short way to describe our different mice.
Wild-type mice have matching letters,
but MINX mice are mismatched. The first letter represents the
nuclear genome, for example, C57 Black 6 in a
CF mouse, and then the second letter represents the genome of
origin for the mitochondrial genome. That would be FVB in this case.
Using two different oncogenic drivers
in transgenic mice, not only is the
primary mammary tumor latency
dependent on mitochondrial genetics, but
the size and/or number of pulmonary
metastases also changes when you change the mitochondrial
genome.
Interestingly,
if you use wild-type cell lines and do an experimental
model of metastasis,
the host mitochondrial DNA can also affect
metastatic burden,
so there's a role for stromal cells.
The most
obvious place we could look first was at metabolism.
And while we saw some select changes at looking at as many as
700 different metabolites or other assays,
nothing was really jumping out at us saying that the mitochondrial genome was
affecting metastasis. It seemed to be really guided by the nuclear genome
instead. So we had to think outside the box.
Comparing the different inbred strains used,
there's a handful of SNPs, several of them in protein-encoding genes, but
there's a little cluster right here.
All of them are in the mitochondrial tRNA for arginine,
and their either insertion or deletion affects
the D-loop of the mitochondrial tRNA for arginine.
Here's the sequence, and this is where the SNPs are.
So a former postdoc in the lab had a great idea.
What if that tRNA for arginine can be cleaved into tRNA
fragments, which go on and have signaling functions?
So we hypothesized that tRNA fragments are being derived from
the mitochondrial genome and that they are influencing metastasis.
There's a precedent for this among tRNA fragments that originate in
the nuclear genome.
And I just wanted to say that we're not
as creative as we think. But, focusing on these
SNPs,
looking at the different strains involved,
you can see that they are, in general, around repeat regions.
That make sense. Polymerase slippage across the evolution of the
different mouse strains.
And we decided to probe on northern blot against different
regions of full-length tRNA. I've highlighted a few of
them here using C57 Black 6 as a reference genome.
And lo and behold, our northern blots demonstrated several interesting
factors.
First, we can see the full-length tRNA, around 70
nucleotides long, as expected. It's a housekeeping molecule, and it
makes for a really convenient loading control.
And we're also seeing smaller fragments of similar
sequence
based on where you're probing the middle region over
here. If we shifttoward the 3 prime end, we
lose resolution of some of those fragments because they're smaller
and encompass a different region.
If we probe the 3 prime end, we lose fragments
completely, even when a little overexposed. We were looking hard for them.
So
one thing to notice is some of the more predominant fragments are around 50
nucleotides in size, others around 40,
and if we
consider the fact that we're not seeing fragments from the 3 prime end
using about a 20 nucleotide size probe, the
70 size molecule minus 20 equals
50, and we would expect this region
to be our fragment.
We also looked at tissue differences in lung and liver, and sex
differences, and saw that the fragment patterns may be tissue and sex
specific.
So what are these tRNA fragment sequences?
Our first attempt at small RNA sequencing did not produce any
reads that were of an appropriate size based on our gold standard
northern blots. And then we realized that in order to
do RNA-seq library prep, you need to have a 5 prime phosphate
and a 3 prime hydroxyl for adapter ligation chemistry.
If your tRNA fragment is being cleaved by an endonuclease that leaves
behind a non-canonical terminus like a cyclophosphate,
then you're not going to get anything out of your library prep.
Also, this was of the human tRNA for
arginine done by mass spectrometry.
There are some methylated adenosines here which could cause
a full stop in reverse transcriptase during
library prep.
So I took a stab at enzymatically correcting the termini of
our RNA and demethylating, and
we ended up with these candidate fragments
sequences, which are about the appropriate size,
matching our blots.
I could talk to you for an hour about the technical difficulties of RNA
sequencing,
tRNA, and tRNA fragments. So suffice it to say these are
preliminary and we're working on an orthogonal approach using Sanger sequencing.
Now, modeling the full length tRNA arginine,
granted AlphaFold is designed for proteins, not nucleic acids,
but it's predicting a more unstable region here at the
corner of the L. And when you compare the different strains,
C3H,
C57 Black 6, and FVB,
looking at the cleavage site from our preliminary
RNA-seq results, there is a slight structural difference there
that could be enough to influence the activity of the endonuclease that
cleaves this site.
Now, that was all in normal tissues.
We're interested in mammary cancer.
So what we did is we took the PyMT mouse
that had been completely backcrossed out of FVB and into the
Black 6 by Leslie Iles here at UC San Diego,
and we crossed that PyMT mouse
with nuclear-matched MIN mice or wild-type control,
and looked for the tRNA fragments in the tumor tissue.
In the CF background, we're seeing an increased production of this
50 nucleotide fragment. That is also observed
alongside earlier primary tumor
latency in the females
and a trend of higher incidence of tumors in the males.
So what we're thinking is,
when there are slight differences in the mitochondrial genome that produce
a different tRNA for arginine,
that tertiary structure may alter how it is cleaved and
produced, and we wonder if that could influence
metastasis downstream.
It could be an oncogenic driver.
So we have a lot of questions left over.
We would really love to lock down the sequence, overexpress
it, neutralize it, quantify it, and really understand
the biologic mechanism that's influencing primary
tumor and metastasis behavior.
So with that, I'd love to thank my lab, my mentor,
Dr. Danny Welch, and
all the wonderful members of the lab and our collaborators,
Isidor Rigoutsos at Thomas Jefferson, and Tony Vandenbush at Synthera,
our biostats and bioinformatics team, and the many students who have
learned from me how difficult it is to handle RNA.
And thanks very much to the University of Kansas Cancer Center
for their support. I welcome any
questions.
Great work. And one question is when you do this
sequencing, you obviously
might also pick up many other fragments.
How many of the tRNAs are full length, and how
many of those do you also see with the shortened form?
You're asking me a quantification question.
Yes. So less than we would hope is the answer.
Because we don't know the
efficiency of the demethylase reaction, we anticipate that it's not
perfect, and when the reverse transcriptase
reaches those methylated bases, it has a choice.
It can stop there and you don't measure anything.
It could do a fidelitous first-strand synthesis
at that point, or it could misincorporate the wrong base.
So the challenge now is how to make the decision about
which
reads to
combineBecause you
may not want to include mismatches because there
actually is one nuclear-encoded lookalike
in the mouse genome here. So it becomes a really difficult
question to quantify,
and that's why we're going with Sanger sequencing as an orthogonal approach.
I'm sorry, that's not the best answer.
No.
Can I just quickly ask?
Yes, please.
Do you see this also for other tRNA MAs, that we have
shortened versions as well?
We have not looked at other transfer RNAs at this time because the
SNPs are all in arginine. But we're hoping to be able to take the
basic biologic concepts we discover and apply them
to human mitochondrial haplotypes down the road, which
are more outbred and more complex.
Thank you.
That was really cool.
My question for you was the heteroplasm mincemeice that you make, are they
100% one type of mitochondria?
Yeah, they're not heteroplasmic.
They are 100% that genotype of mitochondria.
Is there any way of mixing that to-
Oh, you want them to be heteroplasmic?
I'm curious as to what your thoughts are and if you think it's sufficient to
drive your phenotype.
I would have to think about how to make them heteroplasmic because we've spent so
much time how to avoid heteroplasmy.
And what do you think would be downstream of that heteroplasmy?
Because we've always looked at that as a potential problem.
I guess the question is how many fragments
is sufficient to drive your phenotype?
Ooh. Well, for that, we would love to
design an RNA sponge to neutralize it and
then also overexpress it. And I would actually start with a
nuclear vector for overexpression and see what happens,
because again, we're trying to avoid heteroplasmy.
Sure. I think the other interesting thing is just transfer of mitochondria
across cells, too, right?
The lab has looked at that with
the excision microscopy, and they were unable to...
We're not saying that transfer doesn't happen.
We were unable to detect it with that assay.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Very nice talk. I have some more questions.
Great.
So you are looking into the mutation in the D-loop, which is
considered as one of the conserved region of the mitochondria,
because if I remember, that region is sequenced to understand the
human migration. They use that part of the
mitochondrial DNA to understand the phylogeny.
And you have one mutation over there that is associated with that
particular tRNA fragmentation.
So the mutation is there. So why there is tissue
specificity?
Ooh.
Well, why there might be tissue specificity is not
necessarily related to the tRNA structure, but
we would need to know the enzyme that's cleaving it.
We would need to know the chaperones that fold it.
And we would need to know how the changes in that structure, because
the genes that encoded are changed, affect those protein
interactors, I think.
Yeah. Fantastic. Very thought-provoking work. Thank you.
Thank you all very much.
Our
next speaker is Yoriko Ando
from
Japan, the JK University School of Medicine.
So
I don't see your presentation coming up. Okay.
There. Yeah, here.
Okay, please.
Thank you for this opportunity to present at
AACR. My name is Yoriko Ando, and I'm a researcher at
Clive Inc. in Japan.
Today I'd like to introduce our
non-invasive approach for early detection and
prognostic stratification of lung cancer using
urinary microRNA.
This is my disclosure.
In lung cancer is a leading cause
of
cancer-related...
Excuse me.
A cause of cancer-related mortality worldwide, and most
cases are diagnosed at advanced age, and
five-year survival rate
at distance stage dropped to about 10%.
And
even early stage NSCLCs patient
remain at recurrent risk
after curative treatment.
These challenges highlight the urgent need for
biomarkers, enable early detection, and
prognostic prediction.
Liquid biopsies including
CTC or ctDNA,
show
poor sensitivity at early
stage
due to low abundance
of cancer-related material.
The microRNA assay-Have showed some
potential for early detection. But
these broad-based
assay
often shows that affected by
pre-analytical noises such as hemolysis.
And it also need
a clinical visit for sample correction.
So we turn to urine,
non-invasive and
easily
collect collection samples. But it also
raised some questions.
Is microRNA concentration sufficient, or
can urine capture the signals beyond
urological system?
The recent study
began to address these questions.
The urine naturally contains microRNA, but it
also contains other small RNAs such as
tRNA.
But these small RNAs compete
microRNA during a small RNA sequencing,
reducing the proportion of microRNA reads.
To overcome this, we enriched extracellular
vesicle from urine
with
the PEG-based precipitation method.
As a result, the microRNA
reads increased fivefold and the detected
number of microRNA double,
enabling the lowest microRNA recovery.
I'd like to introduce the recent study that
support the use of urine. The Yasutome group
demonstrated,
using mouse model,
that tumor-derived extracellular vesicles
were more concentrated in urine than in plasma.
In this study,
lung cancer cells expressing EV
reporters were transplanted
lung of mice, and
after several weeks later,
the
tumor-derived EVs were monitored in urine and in
plasma. And the signal was significantly
higher in urine.
This result support the use of urine
for EV-based assay.
With this background, let me introduce our study.
This is process overview.
For the early
detection model,
the 278 cancer patient
and 213 non-cancer controls were
randomly divided into two groups, a
trained set and held-out test set.
For the prognostic prediction, a subset of
111 patients who underwent
surgical resection were followed for up to four
years.
And
three milliliter of preoperative urine was
used, and EV
was isolated and analyzed by small
RNA sequencing.
This table shows the demographic characteristics.
The
lung cancer group is much
older,
with a median age of about
73 years, compared to 47 years in
non-cancer group.
And
this difference is addressed in
subsequent analysis. The histology
is dominated by NSCLC, and
importantly, half of the
lung cancer patients were stage zero and one,
reflecting our focus on the early detection.
This is the result of early detection model.
We use the selected microRNA features to train
a
classification model and
achieving AUC of 0.94.
In the independent test set,
it remained high at 0.94.
The detection score was already high at stage
zero and remained across all stages,
with consistent performance
across subtypes.
The early stage sensitivity reached
88%, with the specificity
87%.
The important concern was
whether the
age difference could confound
our results.
We addressed this in two ways. First,
in a age-matched subset of 107 pairs
with median age of 65 and
63 years, the AUC reached
0.94Then second,
multivariate regression analysis showed
that
only cancer statement was significantly
associated with the
scores,
while other
clinical covariates including
age were not.
Next,
sorry.
Okay.
I will now move on the
cancer--
Sorry. Turning now to the development of
prognostic panel. From the cohort of
111 patient, we analyzed 76
patient with stage one and two.
Stage zero was excluded as no
recurrence events were
observed,
and stage three cases were also
excluded because the
outcomes were strongly
influenced by advanced stage and additional
therapies.
To identify microRNAs
associated with recurrence-free survival,
we applied Cox model.
As shown here, 11 microRNAs are
significantly associated with recurrence-free survival,
and the low expression of all these microRNAs
were correlate with poor prognosis.
We constructed final microRNA
prognostic panel.
All combinations up to three microRNAs
among 11 microRNAs were evaluated
by a multivariate Cox model.
And this is the final three microRNA panel with
using these microRNAs stratified
lung cancer patient into high and low-risk
groups.
For recurrence-free survival, hazard ratio was
8.3, and for
overall survival, it was 9.5.
The three-year time-dependent AUC was
0.8.
Okay.
This is the conclusion of this study.
Thank you for the attention.
Is there any question from the audience?
Okay, I can ask one question. First, I would like a clarification
about,
you mentioned tumor-derived extracellular vesicle
that are more concentrated in urine than plasma.
But did you apply some sort of tumor-specific
marker for the extracellular vesicle quantification, or is
it just the global
quantification? Because you mentioned tumor-derived.
Did you quantify specific markers on the
surface?
This one?
Yeah.
Okay. This is not our study, but they transplanted
the
lung cancer cells expressing
the CD9 tags. EV
reporters emit the fluorescence or luminescence
if they have.
Okay, so it was tumor specific in this study.
Yeah, tumor specific.
Okay.
Instead, you are collecting extracellular vesicle as
total population in your
study, so you are isolating extracellular vesicle without any
selection for a specific marker?
No. No specific selection. Yeah, we collect all
EVs.
Okay, and you collect at the diagnosis.
Collect diagnosis?
At the diagnosis of the tumor, so before any treatment, any
surgery, so they were all tested at the diagnosis.
No. We never diagnosed the tumor.
No, I mean,
you sequence the microRNA from the extracellular vesicle that were collected
in urine at the diagnosis of the tumor and not
after treatment, after surgery, so at the moment of the
diagnosis of the patient.
At the moment of the diagnostic, but before the
surgical resection.
Okay.
So you mentioned also a collection
over time, if I am correct. So you collected vesicle
also after surgery
or after treatment.
Yeah, after surgery we did.
Did you analyze the variations in that case, or
do you plan to do that?
Yeah. We
put the data after
the
surgical resection
and
into this model, but the score
doesn't
drop dramatically because
this model is for only
classification between lung cancer and no cancer,
so
the purpose is different, really.
Oh, okay. Okay. So very distinct talk.
The question I have that you started with large number of
microRNAs, then narrowed down to 11, then ended up
with three. So what is your cutoff?
How do you know what level it has to be expressed to
see that can be used as a biomarker?
Again, please? Maybe I cannot understand your question.
Okay. So,
you have three microRNAs-
Yes
... which you think as a signature, right?
Yeah.
So when you analyze, like if you analyze a lot of samples-
Mm-hmm
... how do you know what level it has to be
expressed
to consider as a biomarker?
We
selected this combination with
the hazard ratio.
We compare all the combinations and
we
select the best combination of three microRNAs.
I'll talk to you later. Thank you.
Sorry.
Hi. Thank you for your talk.
I had a question about, I guess, how you were stratifying.
So I saw that you have a few different subtypes of lung cancer in your
patient population. I was wondering if you stratified
based on the subtype as opposed to pooling all of the lung
cancer subtypes together. Because some of those subtypes that you have are
driven by high expression of a microRNA
versus other subtypes are
not driven by high expression of one of the microRNAs.
So, the subtype
is
dominatory by the LUAD, so
most...
I'm sorry.
Can I answer personally? Maybe I should
understand your questions.
I guess I was asking, so I see that a lot of your patients here
are LUAD. I was wondering if you took the subsets
individually and analyzed them individually as opposed
to pooled
together.
You mean when you selected the feature, the predictive microRNA?
Yeah. For one subtype over-- a subtype for small cell
versus
the lung adenocarcinoma population.
To
identify the subtypes or next
challenge, I think.
Okay. Yeah.
So what I understand is they are working on looking into the
subtypes,
and in future, they might come up with the specific microRNA that is
associated with a specific cancer subtype.
And regarding the previous question, what I understand is the
way they have selected these three microRNA is based
on
the overall survival. So they looked into the hazards ratio.
They looked into the expression and survival odds hazards
ratio, and based on the significance of the hazard ratio, they
have selected their best microRNA that
can be used for the detection. That's what I am understanding.
Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
Thank you. Thank you. Very nice talk.
Thank you very much.
Okay. Our
next presentation is by Dr.
Pal. Dr. Pal is from
Stony Brook University, and he has developed
microRNA-based
multimodal therapeutic strategy to overcome
olaparib resistance in epithelial ovarian cancer, and he is
going to discuss about more of his research.
He also
received a Scholar and Trainee Award from AACR, so
congratulations. Dr. Pal.
Sorry about this. I am a graduate student still
now.
Oh, okay.
So
maybe not doctor yet.
Okay. Not yet there. Almost.
Yeah. Thank you. Good afternoon, everyone, and thank you very much
for being here. As I said, I am a
graduate student at Stony Brook University, and I'm really excited
to share our work on developing methotrexate, 5-FU, and
gemcitabine modified microRNA-15a as a
multimodal therapeutic strategy to overcome olaparib
resistance in epithelial ovarian cancer.
And I have no financial conflicts of interest to disclose.
So ovarian cancer is the most lethal gynecological malignancy
worldwide. And among its subtypes, epithelial ovarian cancer
is the most common and most aggressive one.
Most of the ovarian cancer patients get diagnosed at a very late stage
and when the disease has already progressed and therapeutic
options have become limited. But that is not the only
problem in ovarian cancer.
In ovarian cancer, most of the patients initially respond to
existing therapies.
But more than 70% of the patients ultimately relapse,
and the recurrent disease is harder to treat because of drug
resistance.
For example, the development of PARP inhibitors.
PARP inhibitors have significantly improved ovarian cancer management,
but tumors ultimately get resistant to these drugs as well.
More importantly, resistance doesn't arise from a single mechanism.
Tumor cells adapt by-Activating multiple DNA
repair or survival pathways. So we need new
therapies which can target these multiple resistance mechanisms
simultaneously.
This is where microRNAs become interesting.
MicroRNAs are small non-coding RNAs that
specifically bind to the three prime untranslated region of their
target mRNAs by partial complementarity.
So because the microRNAs don't need perfect complementarity, a single
microRNA can target multiple transcripts, and this allows
microRNA to target resistance as a mechanism,
as a network, not just as a single
target agent.
So in cancer, there can be two different types of microRNAs.
One is oncogenic microRNAs, which gets upregulated and promotes cancer
progression. And by suppressing their
activity, we can have therapeutic benefits.
But we are mostly focusing on tumor-suppressive microRNAs, which gets
downregulated in cancer cells, and by increasing their expression in the
cancer cells, we can inhibit tumor cell growth.
And for this, our lab mostly focuses on using microRNA mimics.
But why we chose microRNA-15a?
MicroRNA-15a is a known tumor-suppressive microRNA which
gets downregulated in multiple cancer types, including epithelial ovarian
cancer. And
some of the targets of microRNA-15a, like BCL2, E1, CHEK1,
BMI1, and YAP1, they all are involved in pathways which
drive ovarian cancer progression.
So by restoring microRNA-15a level, we can
reduce the expression of these proteins, and
thereby can inhibit
the tube ovarian cancer progression.
One more interesting fact is that the ATR CHEK1/E1 axis is
heavily involved, plays a crucial role in development of resistance
towards PARP inhibitors. So as we saw that
microRNA-15a targets both E1 and CHEK1, it has the
potential to resensitize the ovarian cancer cells, which has become
resistant towards PARP inhibitors.
Now, to increase the therapeutic potency,
stability, and delivery, we have modified this
microRNA with
two nucleoside analogs, uracil and 5-FU and gemcitabine.
So we have replaced all the uracil and cytidine molecules in the guide
strand using 5-FU and gemcitabine.
And 5-FU and gemcitabine are known chemotherapeutic drugs that
causes DNA damage and replication stress.
On the other hand, we conjugated methotrexate to the passenger strand.
Methotrexate is a folate analog, so it can go and specifically
bind to the overexpressed folate receptors in ovarian cancer
cells, and thereby increasing the tumor targeting specificity.
So with this modified microRNA mimic, we wanted to combine the
tumor-suppressive functions of microRNA-15a
with chemotherapeutic drugs. And we expected
that
this will increase the therapeutic potential of this modified microRNA.
So first, we wanted to test its efficacy
across a panel of ovarian cancer cells with
diverse BRCA and P53 status. And we saw that the
modified microRNA significantly reduced ovarian cancer cell viability
and at a very low dose of at nanomolar concentration.
And most importantly, without using any delivery vehicle, which is a major
challenge in nucleic acid-based therapies.
Also, it was several thousandfold more potent than standard
PARP inhibitor olaparib.
We also saw that the modified microRNA increased apoptosis in
these ovarian cancer cells and caused cell cycle disruption
and as shown by reduction in G2/S ratio.
So this data together suggests that the modified microRNA shows low
nanomolar potency across ovarian cancer models with diverse
genetic backgrounds, like irrespective of their BRCA or
P53 status.
But that was only the part of the story. We wanted to overcome drug resistance.
So for this, we generated olaparib-resistant ovarian cancer cells, as
shown by increased olaparib IC50 values.
And we saw that the modified microRNA showed similar low nanomolar
potency in these drug-resistant cells as well.
It also increased apoptotic cell population and caused cell cycle
arrest, as we also saw in parental cells.
So this data suggests that the modified microRNA retained its low nanomolar
potency even when the ovarian cancer cells
became resistant towards olaparib.
So
next, we wanted to get more mechanistic insights, like how the modified microRNA
works. And for that, we did a whole RNA sequencing and
some KEGG pathway analysis.
And consistent with our design, we saw some upregulation of DNA
damage related pathways and apoptosis and necroptosis.
Interestingly, we also saw that some of the survival pathways like WNT,
mTOR, and AMPk signaling pathway gets downregulated.
So this gives a
overall broad
view how our modified microRNA works, but we also wanted to get
more detailed insights. So for this, we did some heat
map analysis and western blot, and we saw that after modified microRNA
treatment, the DNA damage repair related genes and
P53 pathway genes get upregulated.
And some key checkpoint proteins like E1 and CHEK1, which we discussed
earlier, gets downregulated in both parental and resistant
cells.
At the same time, we saw
activation of genes like
CDK1 and CDC25A, which drives cells
towards mitosis.So to summarize all these findings, we
can say that the modified microRNA treatment increases DNA
damage and replication stress,
which activates p53 pathway. But at the same time, it
reduces the cell's ability to repair the damaged DNA by removing the
cell cycle checkpoints,
and thereby forcing the cells towards mitosis
with damaged DNA and leading to mitotic collapse.
So we took another step, and we wanted to check if the modified microRNA
can be used in combination with other drugs.
So for this, we did a Bliss synergy analysis, and we found that
the modified microRNA shows strong synergistic effect
with
olaparib, which is a PARP inhibitor.
So this shows that apart from using it as a
standalone therapy, we can also use it as a rational
combination partner
with existing therapies like olaparib.
So with this strong in vitro work, we also wanted to see if the similar
efficacy can be achieved in vivo settings as well.
So for this, we generated metastatic tumor model in mice using
both parental and
olaparib-resistant SCOP3 cells.
And we saw that in both cases, the modified microRNA treatment
significantly inhibited metastatic tumor growth.
And most importantly, at a very low dose of only 3.75
mg per kg.
And because we used such a low dose, we didn't see any
adverse side effects like unusual weight loss, hunching, or hair loss.
So this suggests that the modified microRNA is equally effective in
vivo settings as well, and most importantly, well tolerable.
So to summarize, we can say that we have developed a potent multimodal
microRNA-based therapeutics with improved efficacy and
delivery. And the modified microRNA mimic is potent
irrespective of the cell's BRCA or p53 status.
We also saw that it overcomes PARP inhibitor resistance and synergize
with PARP inhibitor olaparib, and it also demonstrates strong in
vivo efficacy with minimal toxicity.
So if we want to say how the modified microRNA works, we can say
that the modified microRNA goes inside the cell.
The guide strand gets incorporated into the
RNA-induced silencing complex, which causes
suppression of its target proteins, which includes WEE1,
CHK1, that leads to checkpoint aggravation.
And also it reduces other proteins like Erp1, BCL2, and BMI1, which
causes reduced survival signaling.
After that, it gets degraded by 5 prime and 3 prime
exonucleases, which releases 5-FU, gemcitabine, and
methotrexate. And all of this together causes replication
stress and DNA damage. And in the same cell,
the convergence of DNA damage, checkpoint aggravation, and reduced
survival signaling overruns the cancer cells and
force towards mitotic catastrophe and apoptosis.
So with this modified microRNA mimic, we are trying
to eliminate all the rescue pathways
that cancer cell can
use to adapt.
So finally, I would like to thank my lab, Dr.
Jing Zhu, Anushka, and other lab members, my department,
Stony Brook University, and finally, AACR for giving me a chance to
present here. Also, if you want to know more about our lab's
research, you can go to poster 625 tomorrow
from 9:00 to 12:00 PM, where Anushka will present her work.
And thank you very much for being a wonderful audience.
I would like to have any questions, feedback, or potential
collaborations and ideas.
Thank you for the nice talk. I'm wondering the
difference between your microRNA MTX,
5-FU,
gemcitabine versus combination treatment of
MTX, 5-FU and gemcitabine. What's the difference?
Can you just repeat the question?
Oh, yeah. You combined microRNA to chemical, right?
Yeah.
So how about treating compound
without microRNA? What's the difference between-
So the microRNA is a tumor-suppressive microRNA,
which means it itself has a tumor-suppressive function,
just that not potent enough. So
by treating these cancer cells with microRNA, we are
removing all the checkpoints or survival signaling pathways.
Like WEE1 and CHK1 are key G2M checkpoint proteins.
So what it does is basically when the cell gets DNA damage,
it pauses the cell from going into mitosis and
try to repair the DNA.
So in your experiment, you treated your
microRNA compound conjugate. So you
didn't compare
combination of three compound with your
compound. So you compared olaparib versus your compound.
Actually, we did compare, but we couldn't show it
here. But the IC50 values that I mentioned here,
like around one to five nanomolar.
Yep.
The
IC50 value combining all these three drugs
is around
500 nanomolar to one micromolar.And also, if you
see here, I have done an apoptosis assay, which shows
that the combination of 5-FU and gemcitabine, the modified
microRNA is
more potent.
Okay, thank you.
Hi. Adrian Charban from Novartis. Thank you for your presentation.
It's very elegant.
I'm less familiar with microRNA. Can you explain
if you're able to have preferential uptake
of the microRNA in the cancer cells versus wild type?
Like normal cells versus the cancer cells?
Yes.
Yeah. To increase the tumor specificity, we have conjugated
methotrexate. So methotrexate is basically a folate analog, which
can specifically bind to the folate receptors.
And epithelial ovarian cancer cells generally overexpress
the folate receptors. So by this, we try
to increase the tumor targeting specificity, but
we haven't shown it here yet.
We are still trying to figure out experiments, how we can show it,
because our modified microRNA is able to
get inside the cell without using any delivery
vehicles. So technically, it can go inside
normal cells as well. But the benefit of
using this,
uh, modified microRNA is that first of all, microRNA is endogenous,
so it's already present in the cell.
Just that in cancer cell, this microRNA gets downregulated, but
it's also present in normal cells.
So
it will have low toxicity because it is endogenous, first of
all, and because we are using it at such a low concentration,
the drugs that are used
to modify the
microRNA is at a very low concentration.
So even 5-FU and gemcitabine will not cause significant DNA
damage that we can see
when we treat with it at a very high dose.
And third of all, normal cells have a very strong
DNA damage repair pathway. So even if 5-FU and gemcitabine
can cause some DNA damage,
these normal cells will be able to repair it.
But in cancer cells, the DNA damage pathway mostly depends
on checkpoint proteins like p53 and BRCA1,
which gets upregulated. If you see here,
in cancer cells, the p53 and BRCA1 proteins gets upregulated.
So because microRNA downregulates the checkpoint proteins and thus cancer
cells will not be able to
repair the damaged DNA, and it will go to mitosis with damaged
DNA.
Thank you. That's clear.
Thank you, sir.
So thank you for the nice talk. My question is,
microRNA itself is how effective to kill cancer
cells? Like, you injected MTX, gem,
many things at the same time. So
specifically, I'm wondering, if you inject only
microRNA-15a into cancer cells,
is it enough to kill or partially kill cancer
cells, or it's too weak?
It can, because if you see the apoptosis result,
you can see that unmodified microRNA itself can induce
some sort of apoptosis. But the
dosage we'll need to use for that will be very high, first of all.
Second thing, the microRNA itself is very unstable, not very
stable. We have seen that after modification, the stability of
this microRNA increases. And again, our whole
goal was to target cancer cells from multiple
ways. In cancer, the main problem is that if you
target one pathway, cancer cell tries to evade that pathway
and activate a separate pathway, compensatory pathway, to
survive. So we are targeting cancer cells from multiple points.
Any other questions? I have so many.
Oh, thank you.
Okay. So,
very nice talk. One thing I still kind of trying to
process how this microRNA complex is
going inside the cell. What is
the pathway? And another thing is, how stable is this complex?
You are simply injecting nucleic acid.
Yes.
So how stable is this, and how it is going inside the cell?
So for our in vitro studies, we have seen that it
can get inside the cells without using any delivery
vehicle. So basically, this
microRNA has both 5-FU and gemcitabine, which
has fluorine molecules. And because of these fluorine molecules,
they kind of increase the lipophilicity of these nucleic acids,
and they can get inside the cells
through
normal diffusion process.
What is the percent uptake?
How much is being uptaken?
We haven't
tried to see it properly, like how much percentage
gets incorporated, but-
Okay. And that's perfectly fine. A working progress.
Yeah.
So do check into that. Another question I have is,
you are modifying one strand with addition of
chemicals.
Yeah.
So you are changing the whole structure.
So how stable is the hydrogen bond now?
So I'm trying to understand, whatever you are delivering is
single-stranded or double-stranded?
We are delivering the double-stranded and we are-
How do you know that?
Uh-
Did you look into that? How stable is the complex?
The complementarity is just because
of the hydrogen bond, and you are adding too much to one strand.
So now are they together?
Yeah.Our lab
previously tried to use single modifications, and they have shown
that the modification doesn't change the Watson-Crick base
pairing.
Okay. So that part has been done?
Yeah, that part has been done in previous papers.
Okay.
Not for this study, but we have already five
modification, only five modification microRNA-15a, and there we
have seen that
this modification doesn't change the
Watson-Crick base pairing.
Okay.
And that's why we can also see the
target suppression in the cells.
Wonderful. My next question is, so,
the microRNA loading to the AGO complex.
Yeah.
And you have MTX along with the miR-15a
sequence.
Yeah.
If I remember, that loading is very tight.
I see based on your
data, it seems like being loaded. So can you
give us some insight, like how it can still be loaded into the AGO complex
and do its job?
I'm
not sure about it
in detail, but...
Look into, think about it.
Yeah.
This is a big question, like that loading to the AGO complex,
like the protein is very tight.
That there is a whole school of theory that this
loading makes the microRNA stable.
Yeah.
So if you have any torsion,
like is it being cleaved before loaded?
Like this part, dig into
it. It will give you some more clues.
So we conjugate methotrexate to passenger strand,
but
only the guide strand gets incorporated into the silencing
complex, right?
So all the modifications are happening on only one strand, like the
gemcitabine and all those?
So 5-FU and gemcitabine modifications are on the
guide strand.
Uh-huh.
And methotrexate is in passenger strand.
Yes.
So.
Okay. So
with those two modifications, is that miR can still load on the
AGO complex?
Yes.
And we have already proved that.
Wow, okay, good. Thank you.
Thank you so
much.
Hello, everyone. I'm here again. I'm Shailend,
and I'm here to
show my gratitude towards the
AACR and the speakers for their wonderful
presentation.
As we come to the close of this mini
symposium, I would like to take a moment to express my sincere
gratitude towards you all and AACR.
I would like to thank AACR for organizing such a wonderful
presentation and conference and giving me
opportunity to interact with you all and
moderate this session. I would like to thank all
the wonderful talks and the speakers.
There were so many talks, and they all are very
thought-provoking. They all give us some new ideas.
They all give us some new questions, and I
think that these all questions will help us
understand the progression of cancer a little more in
detail.
I also want to thank you all.
Because of the audience, because of you all, we are here,
and we are discussing this science.
I would like to pay my gratitude towards the staff members, the
AACR organizing committee. They have been working tirelessly
to make this event pleasant and organize this in
a pleasant way, and so that we can interact.
Thank you all. I wish that this talk must
have given you some new questions.
These talks must have given you some new enthusiasm
and have provided some opportunity to talk with each other and
probably collaborate and try to understand this cancer
progression in a more detailed way, in a more
focused way, and in a way that we can
get together and target it. So thank you so much for
being here. Thank you so much for your willingness to share
your work, and thank you so much for encouraging us to
do what the best we are supposed to do, research,
research, and research. Thank you.